this is not gonna be your typical
airports to video where we just read off
some specs from Apple's website instead
we're gonna be putting apples claims to
the test we're gonna be testing
everything that Apple advertised it with
a new h1 chip including syncing speed
lag when you're watching videos
microphone quality their range because
as Bluetooth 5 now we're gonna test out
hey Siri and a lot more so let's start
out with a connection test the h1 chip
should be faster but it wasn't actually
here let's hit connect and see which one
pairs faster BAM
the new air Potts - did connect faster
there now let's take a second to talk
about the physical differences of course
with the new air pods we have the LED
indicator on the outside of the case
instead of on the inside but one thing
not a lot of people noticed is that the
hinge is no longer polished instead it's
kind of like a brushed finish which does
look nice and it doesn't attract
fingerprints now on the back of the case
we still have that bluetooth pairing
button if you want to pair with other
Bluetooth devices that don't support iOS
instead of being at the very bottom now
it's actually right here at the middle
of the case and of course if you bought
the wireless charging version there is
wireless charging built in and the
design of the actual air pods didn't
change at all they look identical but
what's not identical is the tech on the
inside now let's compare the sound
quality air pods one air pods to
[Music]
it's a pretty good improvement honestly
guys I'm just joking there is no
difference they sound identical and
Apple actually reached out to mkbhd
they're talking about the new air pods
and they said that there is no
difference in sound quality whatsoever
so if you're looking for a sound quality
improvement that's not a good reason to
upgrade now I'm an asphalt 9 Apple did
say the game latency was reduced so I'm
here in the menus and each time that you
hit a tab there's a fact and as I'm
pressing here connected to the original
air pods
I definitely can notice some delay maybe
close to a quarter second after I press
is when I hear the little sound effect
let's check out the iPhone connected to
the secondary air pods that is
definitely noticeable basically as soon
as I press on the menu I hear the effect
right away so if you are gaming with air
pods
I think that'll make a good difference
and now let's check out the auto pause
speed I'm playing a video here let's
remove them well the second gen a pod
pause the video like it should and the
first shiny air pod did it it's still
actually playing let's do that again
test number two all right that time both
of them pause sim I wasn't sure which
one is faster maybe the second generic
pods just by a little bit the second gen
ear pods do have a new accelerometer and
that could improve the reliability of
the double tap function let's go ahead
and test it out I have it set to skip
song
so both of them are seeming to work
perfectly fine I'm hitting him at the
exact same time and the second genera
pods are faster so there you go actually
one time the old gen missed another time
let's give it a second to catch up so
second gen is constantly just slightly
faster so even though we have two
identical phones here the second gen air
pots do switch the songs faster
consistently and along with that they
are more reliable where with the
originals there were a couple times
where it actually didn't switch even
though I did double tap them at the
exact same time as the other side so how
about the microphone quality I have my
voice memos app open one air pod and
each one connected to each phone I'll do
a quick Mic Check
and then you guys let me know in the
comment section below which one sounds
better or are they the same this is an
audio quality test of the original Apple
earpods this is an audio quality test of
the second-generation air pods so now
let's test that one compare my biggest
complaint about the original air pods
and that's switching over from your
iPhone to your Mac now sometimes it
works really well really fast and with a
good connection other times it takes
just a little bit too long three four or
five seconds and sometimes it just
doesn't connect at all let's start out
with the original ear pods I have them
connected to the phone here five seconds
seven seconds I hear sound it actually
paused and there you go so it took
roughly eight seconds or so I'll put the
exact time right over here and the video
actually pause so it can sync up the
sound to the video but watching my lips
right now in this video it's actually
slightly off so it didn't pause enough
to have the audio catch up to the video
and now for air pods too let's go in and
take connect here
the earbuds the cradle cases work
similarly okay so very interesting so as
you can see they did pair a little bit
faster we didn't have that same kind of
a pause for the air pods to sync with
the video and as far as the lips there's
less latency as well now what matters
most for me is a long term reliability
as far as just connecting switching
between devices and we're going to be
testing these out a lot more so if you
guys want to see our full review of the
second gen ear pods make sure you guys
subscribe in able notifications so
finally let's do the range test and see
if the new h1 chip paired with Bluetooth
5 will improve our range and reliability
let's grab these and go outside so I
have one of each air pods in music
playing on both phones I'm gonna hand
these off to a team and then we're gonna
test out the range this is something
that does actually matter to me
personally because often times I plug in
my phone to charge at home and I'm in my
backyard doing some yard work things
like that and sometimes does actually
cut out which sucks get closer or try to
move my phones oh if we can get some
better reach with Bluetooth 5 that would
be really nice
so actually I'm getting some cutting out
with the first gen air pods so Vadim
just told me that our wireless
microphone actually cut out before the
air pods did so the secondary air pods
did go a little bit further and they
were more reliable closer until they
actually stopped working or as the first
gen would start cutting out they'd
connect again start playing start
cutting out again so the total range
wasn't that much better with the second
Gennaro pods but is a lot more reliable
and consistent and finally let's test
out hey Siri and as you can see it
actually pops up really really quickly
it's surprising and that's about the
biggest new feature of the regular
second gen air pods of course we do have
wireless charging if you want to pay
more money or buy the case separately
but we think that most people don't
really need wireless charging in their
air pods the battery life is fantastic
and the case charges in about an hour
from 0 to 100 so I typically just have
to top it off like once per week other
than that there's really not a big
reason to upgrade from the first
generation after the announcement we
knew that there wasn't a bunch of extra
features added or anything like that
just better connectivity in the new h1
chip but as you guys saw in this test
there are some improvements
but they're not that huge so if you have
a good working pair of ear pods I don't
think it's worth of the upgrade with
that set if you're not buying the
wireless charging version the price is
exactly the same as the previous
generation that was so loved by a lot of
people and had one of if not the highest
customer satisfaction so I can't really
fault Apple I'm happy they kept the
price the same and did improve the
product
I do wish maybe we had some different
colors or something like that but we may
see that in the future so thank you guys
for watching if you want to see our full
review after we've used the
second-generation air pods for a few
weeks click that little circle above
this has been max - max tech and I'll
see you in the next video